[Music]
hey guys this is a video about win and
how often you should use a lifting
straps in your training just right off
the bat I'll give my answer and then the
rest of the video will essentially be to
support it
I think for most people most of the time
you should wear straps as often as you
want to or need to and quite a bit more
often than people typically do
essentially what straps let you do is
they let you lift heavier weights or
lift the same weight more times before
your grip fatigues and the
counter-argument people will typically
throw out is well if you can't grip it
you know pulling a deadlift into me you
have to be able to hold on to it
so if you're if you're pushing your
training past the point that your grip
can sustain then you might develop grip
issues which could surface in a meet so
you end up dropping deadlifts I don't
really agree with that line of reasoning
and the main reason for that is that you
can train grip separately when you wear
straps if they do allow you to lift more
weight or lift the same weight more
times then you can train harder you can
train you know if you're dead lifting
you can train your back your glutes your
hamstrings harder because you know you
can lift heavier weights you can lift
the same weight more times you can
probably do more set because your hands
don't end up getting fatigued as as the
workout wears on you know if you're
doing rows typically do rows and stuff
double overhand deadlift you can use a
mixed grip so a lot of people even if
they don't have grip issues dead lifting
they might first a heavy rows or heavy
shrugs and especially for those it makes
sense to use straps because you can
often especially for shrugs use weights
weigh in excess of what you would be
able to grip double overhand and also
you since you don't have to worry about
your grip as much you can focus more on
the muscles that you're trying to train
with those move
you're not worrying about the bar
slipping out of your hands doing rows so
you can focus more on your lats when
you're doing them you you're not worried
about the bar slipping out of your hands
doing RDL so you can focus more on your
glutes and hamstrings and then if you do
have a grip problem or if a grip problem
does develop you can just do specific
grip work the way I see it not using
straps it essentially limits how hard
you can train without really any upside
the only downside to using straps is
that grip issues could potentially arise
but there's a very easy fix for that and
that's just doing more specific rib work
so in general I'm in favor of strap
usage just because they let you train
harder and I'm in favor of anything that
lets you train harder the reason I say
for most people most of the time instead
of all people all of the time is one
absolutes are generally stupid and to
some people especially people with small
hands can actually lift more without
straps than with straps because when you
wrap the straps around the bar
it makes the diameter slightly greater
so if you have really really small hands
that might actually make the lift harder
so for those people mm-hmm well don't
use straps and for everyone else most of
the time wear straps they let you lift
more they let you train harder and then
if you do have grip issues just do more
specific grip work but don't
artificially limit how hard you can
train your back glutes hamstrings your
whole posterior chain just because your
grip is holding you back when you do
have a very easy to use cheap training
tool and straps that could allow you to
train harder all right guys that's it
please like and subscribe and I will see
you next time thanks